former president Donald Trump has also
made a couple stops in Nevada this
election season he's been campaigning
for Republican Senate candidate Adam
laxalt and GOP gubernatorial candidate
Jill Lombardo tonight we have one final
snapshot of Nevada's biggest races it's
an exclusive eight news now Emerson
College the hill poll and spoiler alert
based on this new polling Republicans
are leading almost every major race in
Nevada and the Gap is getting bigger
spoiler alert based on this new polling
Republicans are leading almost every
major race in Nevada and the Gap is
getting bigger if that comes true next
week it would Mark a major shift in
state and National politics
for Democrats trying to hold on to their
political careers the news is not good
the new 8 news now Emerson College the
hill poll shows in the Senate Republican
Challenger Adam laxalt leading incumbent
Democrat Senator Catherine Cortez Master
by Five Points 50 to 45 percent that
marks an eight-point gain for lack salt
from our last poll in September there's
also been a big swing among the key
Latino vote in Nevada laxalt leads
Cortez mazdo 54 to 41 percent that's a
huge change from September when the
senator led by 19 points Congressional
races follow a similar Trend with
Republicans pulling ahead in all but one
contest in District One congresswoman
Dina Titus is behind Republican
Challenger Mark Robertson by 10 points
in District 3 Republican April Becker
leads Democrat representative Susie Lee
51 to 47 percent only in District 4 does
democratic incumbent Stephen Horsford
hold on to a slim three-point advantage
over Republican Sam Peters one major
reason Democrats are struggling is the
lack of support for President Joe Biden
55 percent of nevadans disapprove of his
work just 40 percent support the
president and a hypothetical runoff with
former president Trump Mr Biden would
lose
the number of undecided voters is also
down our poll shows most abandons have
made up their mind and suggests they
want change John langler 8 News Now